in terms of the smells because everyone
assumes that a dead body smells like how
do you deal with that and also do you
use any perfumes or anything like that
no you you never get used to it there is
a smell there there is um you never you
never get used to it it's it's hard I
mean some guys in in the um mtry that
some you know sometimes you put um f
under your nose or some smelling salts
or or you know something but no I I I
with that that's that's just part and
parcel of my job really um but again
when families will say like they use a
certain perfume I would spray that on
them anyway so um but no it's something
that you you do get used to but it is a
it is a a different type of smell